so I'll make home you know what is one
of the sad things to see when you're
leaving the mustard is somebody smoking
a cigarette lighting up a cigarette it's
very disheartening and I got inspired to
make this short little video cover three
important points for someone to think
about next time they're gonna light up a
cigarette the first thing I want to
start off with is the importance to know
that strength is in the surrender when
you're surrendering to the Almighty this
is where you get that power that
strength but when you surrender to your
Neffs this is weakness this is total
weakness and you're being pimped by the
Shaitaan every time you light up the
cigarette the first thing is that as
soon as you light up a cigarette you're
burning money you're throwing money away
imagine how many good deeds you could
have attained by taking that money money
that you would have spent on a pack of
cigarettes I don't know what's a pack of
cigarettes going for nowadays five to
ten dollars and you get buying one maybe
every day every other day it doesn't
matter how much of that money you just
burnt it
you throw it away imagine how much
charity you could have had that money go
towards and you could have racked up so
many good deeds but instead you keeping
this Melek on the left writing the bad
deeds because you're earning the
displeasure of a law second point every
time you light up a cigarette you're
putting poison in your body you're
running towards cancer you're running
towards suicide practically it's like
drinking poison what do you expect when
you drink poison to die so you honey
towards death quickly and we know that
this is something that is definitely
Haram is harming your body and you're
bringing major harm to your body major
harm now somebody might have said 20 30
years ago asthma cruel they didn't know
the science didn't develop but anybody
that tells you that now is out of their
mind it's something that's clearly as
harm is something that's prohibited
third point is what kind of example in
front of the must should we know we live
in this beautiful country that you can't
even smoke in a public place let alone
stand in front of it because they know
smoking a cigarette is not a lot you
have to be like somewhat 7 8 10 15 feet
away do you smoking in front of the
Masjid smoking a cigarette young kid
comes up seeing you what kind of example
are you setting we know that inviting
someone to something good you get the
good reward but imagine you setting some
kind of example like this for the young
kids to see your old man young man
smoking a cigarette believe it you're
gonna be accountable for that you're
gonna be accountable for them so my
advice until you break this habit and
shall all I'll make it easy that you can
if you where there's a will there's a
way
until then go hide under a rock and
smoke these cigarettes don't let nobody
see you doing it it's bad enough you're
doing it but then you're going and
setting an example for it for some other
young kid so remember these three points
and this with love man so if love I'm
delivering this to you and inshallah
this can reach you and hope
you can kick this bad habit connect with
full-on align things possible and find
some way to kick it man you got to get
off this we need to rise above this so
now I'm like a piece